[Música]
economía en directo américa ya está
conmigo en el estudio daniela blandón
dani bienvenida muy buen jueves para ti
feliz mañana vamos a hablar de perú
porque ese país quiere lanzar su propia
moneda digital cómo es eso daniela hola
raúl buenos días pero primero una cosa
usted que cree que a mí nada me gusta
rubén blades y me gusta para que vea que
a mí no me vayan a matar no es que no me
gusta pero no son muy de salsa digamos
agua lista pues mire lo del perú lo
anticipó el banco central de la reserva
específicamente su presidente julio
velarde quien aclaró que es un proyecto
de mediano plazo que podría tomar entre
8 y 10 años y aseguró que desde ya se
está trabajando con otros bancos
centrales de países como singapur e
india y es que son varias las naciones
que están contemplando esa posibilidad
de tener una moneda virtual eso como una
manera de hacerle frente al auge de las
cripto monedas china por ejemplo ya está
probando el joan digital la unión
europea lleva meses planteándose cómo
lanzar un euro digital y eeuu está
haciendo lo propio y ahora dani cuál es
la diferencia de esto con las cripto
monedas bueno a diferencia de una cripto
moneda las monedas digitales son
emitidas únicamente por los bancos
centrales y cuentan con su pleno
respaldo por eso garantizan una mayor
estabilidad y menos volatilidad que las
cripto divisas que no tienen ningún tipo
de supervisión
ahora le pregunto cómo ha sido la
experiencia del salvador con el bitcoin
hablando de esta script humanidad porque
recordemos que hay al bit coin es una
moneda en curso legal vigente en ese
país claro desde septiembre de este año
lo que se convirtió en la primera nación
y no quiere decir que tenga una moneda
digital está utilizando una cripto
moneda y aún con un presupuesto de 2020
casi desfinanciado el congreso le dio al
presidente en allí bukele más de 200
millones de dólares para impulsar la
medida la adopción del bitcoin así
podría entregar un bono de 30 dólares a
cada usuario que descargará la billetera
virtual pero en poco más de dos meses
han surgido dos problemas la falta de
claridad sobre el uso de recursos
públicos para la compra de este cripto
activo y la suplantación de identidad la
organización humanitaria cristo se
presentó ante la corte suprema de
justicia la denuncia de 117 personas que
dijeron haber sido suplantadas para
cobrar este bueno escuchamos se está
solicitando que esté lo que se
establezcan mecanismos de seguridad
inmediata también para que las personas
que sean que se registren puedan
acreditar su identidad de manera
inequívoca pero además se detenga ese
flujo de fondos públicos de recursos
públicos que se están entregando de
manera irregular
raúl es que el presidente también ha
sido criticado porque ha comprado
bitcoins en nombre del gobierno y lo
único que se sabe de esa inversión es lo
que publica por twitter sin dar detalles
algunos y hablando de presidentes del
presidente de brasilia y bolsonaro acaba
de culminar una gira por el golfo
pérsico cómo estuvo esta gira angeli que
buscaba bueno pues mire desde el fin de
semana pasado estuvo en tres países
específicamente en emiratos árabes
unidos- en bahrein y en qatar y buscaba
atraer inversiones pues su ministro de
economía dijo que solo emiratos árabes
unidos- se había comprometido en
invertir mil millones de dólares en los
próximos diez años entre otras cosas
también el presidente inauguró la
embajada brasileña en la capital de
bahréin mañama y también fue a expo
dubai en este último país también tuvo
como siempre su salida polémica cuando
hablo de deforestación lo invito a que
lo escuchemos
para que cubra con cefalea mazón a los
ojos los ataques que sufre brasil cuando
se trata de la amazonía no son justos y
está preservada allí se conserva más del
90% de esa área está estrictamente igual
que cuando fue descubierta en 1500 la
amazonía es fantástica amazona fantas
raúl es que tres días antes de esta
declaración las autoridades habían
revelado que la deforestación en el
llamado pulmón del mundo había alcanzado
un récord histórico en octubre con casi
900 kilómetros cuadrados destruidos
daniela indicadores pues mire iniciamos
con una noticia en la india porque el
gigante tecnológico de pagos digitales
peit y debutó en la bolsa de bombay en
india
tenemos
[Aplausos]
con bombos y platillos esta fue la
salida a bolsa más grande de la historia
de este país pero también tiene su
noticia mala y es que las acciones se
desplomaron un 24 por ciento y llevaron
a perdidas al índice principal de la
bolsa más antigua de asia la bolsa de
bombay y nos vamos para europa porque
las acciones alemanas y francesas van
rumbo a máximos históricos este jueves
por las fuertes ganancias empresariales
danny cifra el día 500 millones de
dólares el banco interamericano de
desarrollo aprobó un crédito por ese
valor para apoyar la financiación
presupuestaria de ecuador y tiene siete
años para pagar bueno usted está
hablando de india y la invito a que
volvamos para la ciudad de bangalore ahí
se va a desarrollar nuestro reportaje
vamos a ver vamos